five years and two spin-off movies later
is everything still awesome the lego
movie to the second part so yeah I went
and saw this and I was a little nervous
but also coming not as much as I have
been with other and made its sequels
lately so like I was very nervous going
to Incredibles 2 and wreck-it Ralph too
because like my immediate thought was
why did these even exist why do we have
these movies with the lego movie - I had
that thought but then again I had that
thought about the first movie before I
even saw it so I felt like this was a
franchise that had already overcome the
very question of why is this a thing
that exists and then managed to overcome
it again with Lego Batman and not
completely faceplant with the lego
ninjago so given that this franchise on
paper has no business existing at all
it's already got a pretty dang strong
track record and the new entry is also
pretty dang good I had someone ask me
after watching it if it's as good as the
first one and I think it might be but
it's not going to have the same impact
because when I say that it's about as
good as the first that's in terms of
like what it's doing and how well it
executes sit and how fun is it but a big
part of that first movie especially was
the newness of it and how fresh it
because like we've really seen that and
hadn't seen anything like that before
and while the lego movie 2 is incredibly
well executed I would say about as well
as the first one it does inherently lack
that that newness so I doubt too many
people are going to particularly adults
are gonna connect with it quite as hard
as they did with the first one just
because it's not gonna catch you
off-guard the way the first one did but
it's really good and surprisingly a man
just to explore a lot of the or in some
ways reacts ploor me examined a lot of
the themes that were in the first one
without it feeling super redundant
there's enough little tweaks that it
actually works surprisingly well um plot
wise I mean I don't until I get into
spoilers in the second half second half
of this video I don't want to get too
much into you know details beyond you
know sort of what you saw in the trailer
it picks up initially immediately at the
end of the first lego movie with the
invasion of the duplo aliens and so we
get sort of an immediate follow-up to
that and then we jump forward five years
and bricksburg has gone from this
shining sort of a well-ordered
skyscraper city to apocalypse burg
it's very mad Max and you know
everyone's in these crazy vehicles that
that they make and everyone's all gritty
and brooding
except for Emmett because he's Emmett
and he doesn't actually really know how
to brood like at all
but then you know it's said that
invaders from the sistar system have
kept coming and kept attacking them and
they saw some heroes had gone to try and
stop that they never came back and when
when another invader from the sistar
system shows up and then kidnaps
basically the key supporting cast from
the first film being Lucy aka wyldstyle
Chara and not Benny it's Charlie days
the voice has flow through mouth Benny
the spaceman metal beard unikitty and
Batman and takes them off and that
leaves Emmett to go and try and save
them and that's our basic plot now there
is a lot more going on with it than that
and as I said it does explore deeper
themes much in the way the first one did
because the first one was very much
about the in many ways misappropriation
of childhood ephemera by adults who
either are sapping the fun out of it or
sort of not letting children play with
toys like their toys
you know sort of that that whole nature
of the quote-unquote right way to play
was very much on the mind of that first
one and this one is playing with some
similar themes and I suppose this is a
little bit I mean it's good let me just
say it's good because I'm in talking
about the themes I'll need to get into
stuff a little bit more like although
returning characters are good the new
characters are good the some of the
things we see in the sistar system I
don't really want as well but it's cool
Izzy it's weird and it's inventive and
there's some surprise cameos that are
really great I good for laughs and also
well executed so I am now gonna get into
spoilers initially it's only gonna spoil
the end of the first lego movie which i
think everybody knows by now but you
know I never know sometimes so the first
one sort of cross over into meadow with
Will Ferrell as a father and then his
son you know his son wanting to play
whereas Will Ferrell just wants to build
and have everything be perfect and
precise and not have fun basically and
what we have here is we have that same
boy now five years later which accounts
for sort of the gritty brooding nature
of you know of bricksburg now being
apocalypse burg you know part of it is
yes everything was kind of destroyed by
the way his younger sister played with
it but it's also he's in that adolescent
phase and so it is sort of clashing
though the way that his sister his
younger sister wants to play in the way
that he plays so while it is still doing
that younger versus older way of playing
it's doing it on a much narrower gap
you're looking at an older younger
sibling dynamic as opposed to a true
adult and child dynamic and that is
honestly different enough that I do
think it is not a mistake for them to
have revisited these same themes
initially while I was watching it
part of me was a little bit frustrated
that they touch on it briefly but they
don't do a lot with what I thought would
have been the really obvious not
necessarily obvious angle but obvious
thing to mine which would have been the
the artificiality of
the idea of girls toys versus boy toys
and how arbitrary that distinction is I
suppose that would have been expecting
too much for them to really dig into
that other than just lightly needle it
seems as Lego itself does actually
engage in that same kind of thing but my
any disappointment I might have had with
the fact that the film doesn't do that
it's not like I think that that's a
topic that needs to be tackled it's just
like well that's it's like right there
in your premise to do that you know why
why would you revisit the same themes
again when you could do that um but they
do the dynamic as I said is just
different enough that I I think they
mind some new things out of it and
especially early on when the duplo
aliens are invading and I'd like this
I'm just talking front end here right
now I'm like I'm so this is still light
spoilers I'm in so when the duplo aliens
initially invade and we sort of get an
extension of the scene from how the very
first movie ended we it really captures
that frustration that I think a lot of
people who either have younger siblings
or had other occasion to try and play
with notably younger kids than them that
you have so like um bat
Batman is fighting one of these things
he throws a Batarang at it and it hits
it and the duplicating goes you missed
me and Batman's like no I didn't or I
think it's metal beard like shoots
lasers at one of them and it just goes
ah lasers like because that's that's the
frustration when you're playing with
someone who doesn't play the way you do
and like you're trying to work with them
but it's like but you just like just
you're not you're just ignoring the
things and I think it captured that
frustration funneled through the
characters I'm actually really quite
well and that sort of thing is played up
very nicely and now I am gonna get into
what I consider to be legitimate
spoilers regarding this movie mean
talking about some of the ending twist
and ending angles so if you are still
here and you haven't seen it and you
want to avoid spoilers this would be the
time to truly duck out so like towards
the end we had
because we had general mayhem who's the
space mask you know kind of character
who kidnaps everybody who takes the mask
off but it's just you know a feminine
looking toy and says to to Lucy to
wyldstyle you know the I thought this is
the only way you pay attention to me and
it it deals with you know I just wanted
to play with you this is what I thought
I had to do in these concepts of image
and how you feel you have to be or have
to look to be quote-unquote mature and a
lot of that comes up with Emmet and
Lucy's relationships where she wants him
to mature and then when he kind of does
she realizes no I didn't want that you
were awesome the way you were and I yeah
this was a mistake
and everything that goes on with the
character of Rex danger vest which who
is funny anyway cuz he very much a
parody of the kind of thing Chris Pratt
plays in basically every other movie
that goes really well it gets really
convoluted at the tail end and I could
tales tell some of the kids in the
audience like weren't following it very
well but as far as the plot machinations
but like thematically fits it fits
really well and I think the songs are
actually catch you're in this one and I
really love Queen whatever which is just
this sort of creature where the blocks
keep rearranging and she's something
else
I think she's incredibly visually
inventive probably my favorite new
character yeah I enjoyed this a lot and
the themes were well explored and and it
came together really well
so the lego movie to the second part
what do you think about it what every
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it things to
do buttons links patreon hey other stuff
to check out but if you don't want to
that's okay because at the end of the
day folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]